Darcy camper gets the nod lingren will back up
tonight for the good guys you're on Ice officials
the referees are bohal Kus and John MacIsaac
leor shanik and Matt mcferson are on the lines
and Taylor's career an inl four all the time on
the rotation play that just skipped past alexv
BL jackobs will funnel this back to Center as we
near the seven-minute mark two-on-one developing
fanelli fires good saved by keer the Caps have
to vacate the offensive territory texier sends
it out wide good send in there from serson
to bemstrom one more and a good stop there
at the end of the line keer made the rejection
on texier yeah just cucked it with his catching
glove texier tried to go upstairs slot pass
looking for Carlson a wraparound chance and M
leans gets back to the post good Tempo so far in
this game almost 9 Minutes deep from Capital One
Arena Milano bracketed by Defenders he'll clear it
in dowed in a foot race with rensky watch them go
to the glass marchenko bookended cus back to
point position Johansson drops it off Alexia
fires that was routine for M leans that team was
loaded not to in The Winner Circle though at the
end of the NCAA tournament cross eyes great
look closing in snapshot just failed to turn
the red light on a great chance there what's
most important to do on the power play just
that puck movement Jo it starts with the entry
I thought the entry on their first part of this
power play was excellent it was all about KZ Nets
off speed and he just push back everybody they've
got to get an early entry here garc keer for the
Caps tonight Johnny gdo not 6'5 plays it back to
the point Bean rer on the way Shrugged aside by
keer Carlson fails to clear Jenner steps in and
fires snapped out of the air by keer best save of
the hockey game between these two goal tenders a
30 goals is his high he had 23 and 26 the last
two years he's right up there usually among he
got right back up and know that he can bounce
back like that KET off zooms through plays it
out wide to McMichael front door there boxed Away
by Ms leans Wilson will revolve through Center
well don't players always say you can never
get the real feel of NHL hockey in practice
I mean he can take contct and things like that a
little bit in practice that's not the same thing
he just took there from Morky Wilson gliding in
forced Away by bean bean closing well and it's
Amil bemstrom back for a potential two-on-one
with texier texier saucer pass One Touch they
score beautiful combination play for the finish of
Jenner no Jenner had had a great early opportunity
and here he finishes off this three-way passing
play here they are coming up alexf tries to come
across there's the Tic Tac Toe the captain
has given Columbus a one- nothing lead here
beautiful pass by bstrm who threads the needle
pressured quickly by Dow John Carlson at Point
position sandine for Dow fan on that one worked
out well one timer score John Carlson drops the
hammer Carlson ties it up looking him find
it on the far wall and that is harder than it
looks he's against the boards Dow keeps the puck
gets around the forward pan Tilly the youngster
weasles his way there and finds John Carlson
sharp angle shot this will be Flex towards the
front alexv on patrol for the Caps Backstrom play
it out wide Oshi Oshi turned and run to the ditch
there defensively to the front deflection try at
the line no oetkin thought he had the preseason
goal it's washed out with a Columbus Defender
right along the goal line referee halus let's
take a look one more time for the first time
here it is over the line kicked out however
you see Rover off looked like he did kick it
out didn't he even though he's falling into
the net there's his right Skate coming in who
Nets off on for the young Winger further ahead
to John Carlson two-on-one developing Carlson
closing poke check there by m leans it was a
two-on-one 20 minutes left in this preseason
Tom Foolery before it all starts for real with
the caps and Penguins on Friday the 13th te
just a reminder lengthy pregame coverage on
Monumental Sports Network for that one pregame
live red carpet live all coming your way on the
network four on four hockey for 28 seconds at the
outset of the third the dangerous line a rips one
right on to Darcy keer mark keer down for a
dozen stops good throw to the outside line a
cruising in Stick check by sandine yeah tried to
make a little move there bounced off his dick an
oldfashioned wrist shot to start the period
from L Patrick l has possession of the puck
cross ice a nice pass went beneath the blade of
serson who Nets off on the button sandine alone
to his backand stopped by m lein excellent pass
I talked about kozi in between periods passed by
kazet off here he picks it up and look at him
C sandine burning between 2D per over off got
caught black footed as did L great opportunity
for sandine Cam's got got to be close by there he
played a lot of years how about Mike can there's
another one how about Brendan Morrison how about
the how about the longtime coach red baronson
he scored a lot of NHL goals too yeah but the
correct answer is Max pachetti like canal and
Morrison they were four-year Wolverines vantilly
and petti right in right out of an didn't stay
long did they nope but they uh had VIP cards at
Zingerman's Deli though oh my favorite when I it
when I sto there for football or for lacrosse inti
singer denied rebound they score this game is
tied yeah great save on the follow up a penalty
was going to be called there for the hook and
they kept the play alive and cylinder is going
to put it in Columbus Blue Jackets here it is
off the draw caps actually win it and then they
play footsie with the puck there's the trip and
and then the followup they switched some lines
around here in the third he gets some time with
L and gdo didn't find a home and Severson was
not able to keep that one in they didn't find a
home because of defensive posture Nick Backstrom
texbook down low working as a center working
in unison with the Caps defenseman Fant Tilly
powering in with marchenko Van Tilly scores a
sneaky release from the rookie turns the light
on that sure was that is a sneak attack release
when he didn't even hardly lift up his stick
take a look at this play coming across gets it
and just shoots in one motion doesn't use any
weight transfer whatsoever 32 Columbus Jenner
made it one- nothing singer and fantelli here
in the third off of Steel centering pass Great
Stop M leaking fantastic save against mcel very
casual with the pck line he's not going to like
that play that he just made awful turnover the
Caps couldn't capitalize the left pad of M
leak the difference Milano full flight works
his backand M leens gets that with a blocking
blove 250 left in regulation we'll keep our eyes
on keer see when he'll be lifted for the extra
skater bang bang play from Phillips toome denied
again M Le for the time you have worked here in
Washington on so many different levels and so
many different capacities hard pressed to find
a better historian than Al as the Blue Jackets
cinch this one with an empty net goal from line
yeah and the Caps thought it was a little bit of
a hook on the hands that led to L to strike here
a little Play Down Low there's a little dump in
watch a little lift check right there and the key
thing is on the wing through protus M lein who
was incredible in the third period at times will
get the win for his mates a 4-2 decision in DC